find a hundred million dollars you only
would spend it and creating immediately
a network of people in the world that
would engage in personal transformation
in collective transformation and in
creative problem-solving to solve the
four major areas in our world that need
to be immediately healed the environment
social injustice conflict resolution and
and poverty which is the cause of so
many other problems including diseases I
think I would use the hundred million to
create a world wide net of consciousness
much more than the internet it would be
a network I would be able to harness the
collective creativity for problem
solving there is already great data on
the fact that if you put a few people
together in the room and you give them a
problem and if they're not specialists
they will solve it if they're
specialists their minds will never go
out of the box so this is the opportune
moment to harness the collective caring
and the collective creativity and
recognize that human development is much
more important than development in the
classical sense so no amount of pouring
money into you know solving a problem
one problem at a time will solve the
problems with the world we've tried it
in medicine as soon as you 12 one is you
treat one disease something else crops
up you have to create balance in the
total body mind system and this you know
establish that integration between body
mind soul and spirit and I think the
hundred billion dollars could be used to
just focus on one idea and that idea is
well-being well-being of the individual
well-being emotionally well-being of our
relationships well-being of our business
is well being of our economy well being
of our ecosystem and well being of the
world at large it's a broad term but it
all it means is restoring balance and if
you can think of all the ways that we
can harness the collective intelligence
and the collective compassion and one of
the ways to do that by the way through
storytelling there's nothing more
transformational than a storytelling so
I would create a huge Network
Information Network which would take
everything into account educational
institutions entertainment music news
networks information technologies the
internet and saturate this network and
these technologies with stories that
have the power to transform